todo el mundo quiere celebrar el 8 de
marzo del día internacional de los
derechos de las mujeres hasta las
grandes empresas como Barbie pero este
año desde la multinacional de muñecas
han querido ir un poco más allá y
reivindicar otra minoría estigmatizada
las mujeres afro sacando a la venta a
una muñeca de la científica espacial
Maggie Adri poco
algunas personas se sorprenden de que
una mujer negra sea científica espacial
me gusta romper esos estereotipos
siempre que tengo la oportunidad
la puesta de Barbie no es casual adherir
un poco es expresidente de la asociación
científica británica muy conocida por su
trabajo con el telescopio James webb y
por presentar el programa de Sky at
Night de la bbc y quiere animar a más
niñas a tener carreras como la suya una
de mis misiones en la vida es tratar de
animar a las niñas en materias como
ciencia tecnología ingeniería y
matemáticas son demasiado importantes
para dejarlas en manos de los chicos su
muñeca lleva un vestido azul estrellado
que evoca al cielo nocturno un
telescopio para ver las estrellas e
incluso sus características mechas Y es
que la científica quiere hacer que las
niñas afro se sientan identificadas
cuando era niña las Barbies no se
parecían en nada a mí así que tener esta
que soy yo literalmente fue muy
emocionante esta doctora tiene muy clara
sumisión en la vida animar a las niñas a
perseguir sus sueños hasta alcanzar a
las estrellas